I have such sympathy for people who are
poor that I want them to be rich here
are the steps that are required to be
rich there's a difference in offending
people by saying things that are true
and offending people because you're
being a Traditional Values have become
something that you have to whisper to
your friends about we spend seven
figures a year on my personal safety
seven figures here what makes you think
you're so special everyone who's pitched
you is worse at this than I am I'm
better at this than anyone on the planet
could you see yourself at some point in
the future running for a president
you guys may have noticed that this
podcast is always a place for open
discussion where ideas are fairly
considered and honestly confronted
unfortunately it's actually extremely
difficult to find places like that in
today's media landscape I know for me
I'm always looking for unbiased media
but it seems like everywhere I go
someone's trying to shove an agenda down
my throat so how do you know you're
seeing the full story well today's
sponsor ground news is a website and app
that shows you the inherent bias in news
coverage and reveals the stories that
you might be missing for every story you
get a visual breakdown of the number of
sources reporting on it and where they
fall on the political Spectrum giving
you instant access to different
perspectives you could directly compare
headlines and read the full articles to
compare any bias they might be having
like here you can see one news article
from the left that claims that Adam
slams hocal and migrant crisis but the
right says the tour at odds being able
to see both sides of any debate is the
only real way to get the full picture
there's even a feature called Blind Spot
which I find really cool which shows you
stories that are heavily covered by just
one side of the political aisle so then
you know if a topic is avoided by one
side or the other and now grab news is
offering 30 percent off their Vantage
plan with their link Down Below in the
description this includes access to a
personalized news dashboard where you
can keep track of your reading habits
and make sure you're not stuck in a
biased media bubble ground news is the
best way to stay on top of everything
going on get the full picture think
critically and then come to your own
conclusion so go to ground.news ice to
get 30 off or visit the link Down Below
in the description it would seriously
mean a lot guys thank you so much ground
news and onto the podcast we're actually
going to start this off with a fan
question okay biggest fan one of my
biggest fans okay found them you ready
hi Ben I'm a huge fan of yours so
excited to ask you a question
um I've seen you talking about Barbie a
lot do you think that you are enough
like do you feel enough in this
matriarchal society I'm definitely
Beneath You're benoff I'm Bena that's
you've been creative I don't think that
that Ken is a good role model Ken's not
a good role model no Ken is a bad role
model what do you say first of all I
liked the Barbie movie
it was a fun light-hearted movie got me
laughing some of the jokes in there
that's yeah you're allowed to you're
allowed to enjoy it you're wrong but
you're allowed there's nothing against
American law that forbids you from from
enjoying the Barbie movie it just means
that I have questions about your taste
and Brett's taste and Michael moles's
taste and half the people work for me so
you know there there you have it so who
was that that asked the question right
there that is Brett Cooper and how do
you know Brett uh so Brett is one of our
hosts uh she hosts a terrific show on
YouTube with a massive following and we
share a pair of eyebrows that is that is
what we're famous for but also the
intonations of your voice the way you
speak you have so many mannerisms that I
think you're like almost identical
between you two I haven't seen that but
maybe it's one of those things where you
can't see the air that you're walking
around in I think I don't spot enough
things about myself perhaps and so yeah
she couldn't see it either but we had
all the comments say we thought that was
like a younger sister yeah everyone
thinks you guys I will say that I have
three younger sisters and at least one
of them looks kind of like Brad I mean
they're they're not they're not wildly
off that's funny I mean my younger
sister classically Abby who's on YouTube
also and there's some resemblances to
Brett and they're not like wildly
desperate looking have you done a DNA
test though
um I mean I'm I'm fairly certain there's
no relation and the reason I say I'm
fairly certain is because at one point
we did do like a 23andMe DNA test and it
came with 100 ashkenazic Jew and I'm
pretty sure that's not Brett Cooper's
background that would make sense so yeah
that's that's pretty closed
you know ethnic ethnic Loop right there
so she's talent for your media company
the daily wire yes now how did you get
to the spot of owning a massive Media
Company the daily wire talk us through
the chronological sequence of events in
your life that brought you to that
prestigious role so you fail a lot of
times right I mean this is true for
every single person I know who is
incredibly wealthy and successful which
is everybody looks at them and like ah
they must have hit it the first time or
they became wealthy and that was like
when did the magic happen and the answer
is you labor in the minds for you know a
decade and then eventually you hit on
the thing and you've gotten good at the
thing at that time and so yeah basically
the story goes like this and I'll try to
do this in sort of a succinctive fashion
as I can so I started UCLA when I was
16. uh I got a syndicated column on
politics when I was 17. that was because
I've been writing for the UCLA daily
Bruin and I was writing sort of a point
Counterpoint column and that turned into
a regular column and I went to my father
and I said do you think that it's good
enough to be in like regular newspaper
and it came up with this indicator
called Creator Syndicate which would
take columns and send them out to 100
papers across the country and so they
picked up the column they didn't know
how old I was so they were kind of
surprised when my parents had to sign
the contract so I was still a minor and
I started writing a syndicated comment I
was 17. pretty much every dumb column
I've written by the way is between the
ages of like 17 and 23. but I would say
like the vast majority of dumb things
I've said were during that period uh you
know because that's usually when you say
most dumb things in your life in any
case I finish UCLA I read a book while
I'm at UCLA I go to Harvard Law I
started there when I was 20. and I write
another two books while I was at Harvard
Law by the time I leave Harvard Law I
decide I want to work at a law firm or
at least give it a shot and I really
want to learn how real estate works
because everybody whom I know who's Rich
has real estate holdings and so I figure
okay I'll learn that industry the
problem is I join this firm Goodwin
Proctor which is a major national law
firm I joined them in the in September
of 2007 which is probably the worst time
in human history to join a real estate
law firm because that is precisely when
the real estate market is collapsing
right that is the subprime mortgage
crisis and so I'm sitting in this
beautiful office overlooking Century
City every day for like 10 hours a day
doing nothing and they're getting
increasingly upset because I'm not
billing hours and when they do bring me
work then I'm doing the work too fast
because this is sort of one of my skill
sets I speak fast I type fast I write
fast I edit quickly that is not what you
want as a lawyer who's building hours
when you build hours this is why I hate
you know actually how law firms work
they bill you by the hour so it
disincentivizes efficiency it's really
bad so you know I I decided I couldn't
take it and after about 10 months I had
met my wife during this period after
about 10 months I turned to my wife and
she turned me and she's like you're
miserable you should just quit and this
is right before we were about to get
married and I was like well we just got
a condo we just got a mortgage and we're
about to get married and she's like yeah
but you're miserable you should quit so
I quickly win Proctor and I took a job
for one-third of the pay working as a
lawyer in-house counsel for a company
called Talk Radio Network which is the
radius indicator for Michael Savage and
Laura Ingram because I wanted to be in
that industry but I ran column for years
I already had books at this point but I
wanted to learn the radio industry
because I grew up listening to Rush Rush
Limbaugh and in La Larry Elder and so I
made a deal with the company and the
deal with the company that I was working
for was I would spend half of my day
doing legal work because they needed an
associate in-house Council and I would
spend half of my day doing production
work I wanted to learn inside out how
the industry worked so I would sit there
and I would cut the audio clips like
with the actual sound program probably
half the clips that you heard on Michael
Savage's Laura Ingram's show between the
years like
2009 to 2012. I cut those uh so or if
there's Montage I was cutting that or if
there was a monologue by one of the
hosts there's a possibility I was
writing talking points that sort of
thing in the meantime I was also ghost
writing books so I I cobbled together a
pretty good living doing ghost writing
of books because I can write quickly so
Publishers would come to me and they
would say we have three weeks for you to
turn in a book from this personality who
doesn't know how to write a book and I'd
say okay and I'll just churn out a book
in three weeks and so you put together a
few of those a year
plus you know whatever income I was
making for my own books plus columns
plus speaking plus the plus the job and
it worked out to you know not amazing
income but like definitely a livable
income it was it was not what I'd been
making at the law firm but it was
two-thirds to three quarters of what I
was making at the law firm I worked
there for about three years and then
there came a point where I just couldn't
see a future at that company or for that
company it didn't seem like a direction
that I that I wanted to continue moving
at that point I went out on my own and I
was basically making a living ghost
writing alone and doing doing those
sorts of things and this is in
2012. I graduated UCLA in 2004 so it's
been eight years uh nine years since
I've known Andrew I've known for a
decade at this point I'm in my mid-20s
I'm talking to Andrew and Andrew's like
you know we really need an editor at
large over here at Breitbart we need to
staff up so would you like to would you
like to come work over here so I joined
on at Breitbart as an editor at large
when I was in my mid-20s and I was there
for
let's see 2012 to 2016. so I was there
for about four years as always I had
multiple streams of Revenue so this is
this is sort of how I did my career
until I found the thing that worked so
one of my sort of career principles
especially early in your career is
pursue as many opportunities as you can
attempt to do well and then find the one
that actually works and then put all
your efforts into that so it's a
diversification strategy by the way also
a pretty good investment strategy yeah
it's a diversification strategy for your
time and for your career if you can do
it and then you find the thing that
actually works and then that's where you
push so while I was working there I also
got a job simultaneously as the uh one
of the three people on an LA radio show
an LA Morning Show I started doing that
about a year and a half after that I got
an afternoon Radio Show in Seattle so my
schedule at this point and then I also
launched a website with the David
Horowitz Freedom Center that was called
Truth Revolt truth Revolt was basically
the predecessor to daily wire it was
designed as reverse Media Matters so the
basic idea was that the left likes to
initiate boycotts against the right and
get those shows canceled and so we don't
like that tactic but the only way that
people are going to back off that tactic
is if that is mutually assured
destruction as if everybody understands
the tactic is bad so we're just going to
avoid that tactic by the year 2014 my
schedule went like this I'd wake up at 5
30 in the morning I'd go work I would go
do my morning show uh from six to nine I
would then edit at Breitbart for a
couple of hours a day and mostly by that
point I was writing just kind of these
long pieces for them so I'd write a
piece a day for Breitbart I was editing
I was editor-in-chief uh with my one of
my business partners is daily wire
Jeremy boring and I can explain how
about Jeremy in a second we were running
through the world together so I was
editing he was mostly doing the business
side I was doing the editorial side so I
was editing truth revolt and then I was
doing an afternoon radio show for three
hours a day so I was working four Jobs
Plus ghost writing plus writing my own
books plus speaking so I mean
technically speaking I was probably
doing six or seven jobs over the course
of a week and Via all of these
mechanisms I was now making a pretty
good living right because each one of
these paid fairly well so I was probably
making uh at this point somewhere around
400 000 a year that's fantastic between
between all between all those jobs no
well it's so here's the thing it is a
really good living also my first year
out of law school when I was working at
the law firm I was making 180 right when
you come out of Harvard Law and you're
and you're working in a law firm 180
without bonus was like the norm so like
200 was kind of your Baseline now listen
I I have a lot of advantages in the
sense that I grew up in a two-parent
family with a lot of family security not
Financial Security but family security
my parents are not relatively I grew up
in I grew up in a house I grew up in
1100 square foot house in Burbank
California with three sisters one
bathroom two bedrooms
um shared a room with all three of my
sisters until I was 11 years old so we
weren't Rich by any stretch of the
imagination but my family is very very
solid so
I always felt like you know worst case
scenario if all else fails I still have
a wonderful family I could move back in
with my parents for a little while until
I get back on my feet I had a Harvard
law degree that's worth a lot of money
so you know I had that kind of in my
back pocket that allowed me to be more
risk seeking in the way that I
approached my career I mean when I first
when I first met my wife I told her I
remember we were dating and she said you
know we were talking about kind of what
what does the future look like we were
talking about finances and I said I'm
I'm gonna make millions of dollars I'm
gonna make a lot of money was it the
first time you met her uh that was not
in her first date that was probably in
life that was probably in like our outs
that was once we've gotten a little more
serious so for us that meant like our
fifth day because yeah exactly I mean we
had our first date on September 5th and
then we were engaged December 22nd and
it's 2008. so there's not a ton of time
there yeah um but yeah I mean when and I
remember her laughing and thinking that
was selling in fact one of one of my
favorite stories about that is that
um my father-in-law so in the Jewish
Community when you get married you sign
a marital document that basically looks
kind of like a bring up and this is a
historic document going on way back to
the talmud called the katuba one of the
things in there is like an actual
breakup fee right if if the marriage
breaks up then how much money do you owe
to your wife and so in most Jewish
communities it's kind of a de minimis
amount because it's basically pro forma
but in the Moroccan Community this is
like a point of pride is that you go to
the wedding my wife's of Moroccan
extraction and you go to the wedding and
somebody reads the amount over goes ooh
ah all right so my father in law sits me
down one day this is right before we're
getting married and he's like I have a
very important question to ask you I was
like okay and he's like how much money
do you want to put in the katuba and I
was like I don't care don't matter to me
I'm not we're not getting divorced so
put whatever you want like literally
whatever you want I don't care and he's
like well you you name the number all
right fine put 10 million dollars I
don't care and he looks at me and he
starts laughing he goes she's not worth
10 million dollars we'll put a million
dollars and um I frequently remind him
that he is a horrible negotiator so wait
wait um but I'm confused so if you put
let's just say a million dollars in this
is that what's split upon no that's what
you owe her that's what you owe her is
the guy owing the girl yes that document
yes even if the girls they hire her yes
that is customary yes I mean it's
historic document that goes back a
couple thousand years based off of any
sort of like financial status beforehand
or maybe what you're projecting no I
mean you can negotiate it so I'm I'm
under the impression a brother-in-law of
mine who's a little older than I am
actually negotiated it out like because
he's also Moroccan so they both took it
super seriously like I took it not
seriously at all I'm like whatever it
doesn't matter customary to negotiate
with your future father-in-law I mean
trying to get this are you trying to get
it down he's trying to get it up I mean
apparently if you both take it seriously
that's a thing right for me I didn't
care I'm very American so I was like
whatever it doesn't matter um yeah
everything's community property anyway
it's California like right that's it's
actually but that of course that never
entered my mind but I I turned him today
and I'm like you know that like you
really jacked your daughter in this
document
you put her in a Barrett so with that
supersede then the California's
community community problem in that case
it probably not I mean so now you get
into sort of abstract issues of Jewish
law and whether you inside the Orthodox
Jewish Community are allowed to go
outside to a secular Court to have
adjudicated your divorce when it's a
religious institution or whether you go
to a secular Court in order to do that
like these are actually really
interesting and complicated issues of of
Jewish law versus secular law and which
governs and and that sort of stuff is
kind of interesting in any case
um you know so you know by by this time
this is right before the launch of daily
wire so but we've gotten up to like 2015
I'm working like six seven jobs I'm
cobbling together maybe four hundred
thousand dollars a year somewhere in
that neighborhood
um and uh and then we make a pitch to
truth Revolt which is the main job that
both Jeremy and I have right that's
where the vocal man income is coming
from I'm getting you know 75 grand from
one place I'm getting a 100 Grand from
another but like the bulk of my income
is coming from this and um we just again
just taking a mortgage so by this point
I've already lived in this is my third
house we had a condo we sold it to buy
up we sold that to buy up we had just so
we had just closed out a really really
nice house in L.A and so we do a meeting
where Jeremy has come up with a strategy
and Jeremy
so I can backtrack here to explain kind
of my relationship with Jeremy for those
who are interested because Jeremy
obviously is now personality in his own
right and with Jeremy's razors and
Jeremy's chocolates and the whole
godcage thing and all that so I've known
Jeremy since like 2009. uh so I've known
Jeremy for quite a while and he and I
met while I was working at talk radio
network we really hit it off and we
started immediately talking about like
what are ways we can do business
together and so I started kicking him
business I started like finding him
projects that he could do for other
outlets that like scribing videos
YouTube kind of videos which kind of
broadened the scope for him and created
a body of work that he could then pitch
outside well in about 2014 he and I were
talking and I was working at Breitbart
at the time and uh he had been talking
with the folks at David Horowitz Freedom
Center and it was his idea to get me
into David Horton's Freedom Center to
launch truth Revolt so now he and I are
actual business partners by that point
we're actual business partners we
proposed a few businesses before that
very since Andre not a lot of money a
couple thousand bucks a year like but we
we've been working together close
friends and all that so we we go to
truth Revolt truth Revolt is doing
pretty well and Jeremy hits upon a
revelation and there are two big
revelations in sort of my relationship
with Jeremy Revelation number one comes
in 2013 when I do the Piers Morgan
interview about what happened yeah you
accused me of standing on the grades of
the children that died there how dare
you I've seen you do it repeatedly
Pierce like I say how dare you I mean
you can keep saying that but you've done
it repeatedly because up until that
point in our partnership and our
friendship basically the Assumption was
I was the business guy and he was going
to be the talent because he'd always
want to be a director and and he came to
LA to be an actor and he had been in
writer's rooms and all of that and I was
this I went to Harvard Law School I've
been the Executive Vice President of
talk radio network all of this kind of
stuff in 2013 I do the interview with
Piers Morgan on CNN about gun control
and it goes absolutely berserk on the
internet I mean it was like the biggest
thing on the internet for a solid month
and Jeremy I remember I talked to him
beforehand and I told him what I was
going to do during the interview and we
had discussed him we had strategized and
that kind of stuff and um and after the
interview he called me up and he said we
have this completely backwards I'm the
business guy and you're the talent so
that was you know all credit to him on
that one I mean it takes an act of
humility truly to be able to say like no
you need to be the you need to be the
front man when you've always thought you
were the front man you needed the front
now now it's great Jeremy also gets to
be a front man but that but at the time
that was a really big Revelation so that
was Revelation number one and Revelation
number two comes in 2015 when Jeremy
realizes that the way that we had been
doing our website for a while and the
way that traffic used to be done on the
internet at least on the right is if you
wanted traffic on your website you
basically needed a drudge link you
needed a link to Mac dredge's website it
was the like everyone knows this on the
right a link from drudge was like the
magic thing that caused your website to
explode I mean Andrew Breitbart
breitbart.com was built on the back of
the links from Matt drudge that's where
the traffic was built from and so you
would hunt for dredglings you'd like
create a story you'd send it to Matt or
one of his editors in hope against hope
that he would post it well in 2014 2015
Germany and I are discussing this and I
turned to Jeremy and and I said what
became sort of the first of our business
aphorisms which is luck is not a
business strategy right you can't rely
on the kindness of strangers we're not
Blanche Dubois here like we actually
need a strategy and Jeremy said well I
want to look into this and so he he
started looking into it and he came up
with this marketing strategy and he
realized that there was a real Arbitrage
opportunity in Facebook that Facebook
was where all the crowd was all the
eyeballs were that the cost for
advertising on Facebook was pretty
affordable and that the and that the
draw from Facebook in terms of traffic
was really high so he says let's set up
a meeting with the board over at David
Horowitz Freedom Center and let's pitch
them so you get them in the room and
Jeremy starts making the pitch which is
we're going to spend we need one million
dollars and if you give us one million
dollars we will generate you a money
machine that lasts for all the time and
he explains the whole plan and they do
not get it because everybody on the
board is like 80. very nice people but
they're all 80 and don't know what a
computer is let alone what internet is
and so Jeremy's explaining this and if
you've ever met Jeremy Jeremy and my our
styles are completely different in terms
of how we communicate Jeremy is from
Slaton Texas he's got a soft Texas Lil
speaks a lot slower than I do I'm like a
fast talking Jewish kid from La yeah and
normally the way this works is that I
make a pitch and then Jeremy has to come
in and like speak softly I used to call
him the stupid Whisperer because
we met with a lot of Congress people and
every conversation went like this I
would explain a thing they wouldn't
understand Germany would re-explain the
thing but slowly and in Texan and
suddenly they would understand in any
case this time it goes backwards Jeremy
explains the deal they do not understand
it at all they turn to me we've been
doing this for like an hour and a half
they the board turns to me and they're
like can you explain this in like more
simply like try to boil it down at this
point I was really frustrated and pissed
and I take out a napkin and a pen I say
here is our business plan dollar sign
Arrow Facebook Arrow website Arrow back
to dollar sign this is our business plan
I literally did that on a napkin I
turned it around we're gonna spend money
on Facebook Facebook is going to
generate traffic for our website we're
going to monetize that through
advertising and subscriptions
back to Facebook right and we're just
gonna spin up yeah that's right that's
that's how that's how we're going to
generate our business they fired Jeremy
the next day and uh in solidarity they
want to keep me on a sort of like a face
for for the website and I quit I was
like this you can't fire my friend my
business partner and I'm not gonna stick
around for that so now we're both
jobless we both had new mortgages and so
we're but this idea we know is a thing
and I know and at this point we know a
few things we know that we know that
Jeremy is capable of running the
business side of this because he did it
with truthful we know that I'm capable
of editing websites I did with Breitbart
and I did it with truth Revolt we know
that I'm capable of drawing a crowd I've
done that multiple times and so we we
have the skill set that we've both been
practicing in our various sort of arenas
for a while so we decided we're going to
go out to Market we have two choices at
this point Choice number one is we
mortgage our houses and just do the idea
ourselves and this was you know in
retrospect what we probably should have
done yeah um but at the time you know I
let's see this is 2015 so at this point
I had uh one kid and a second almost
there uh and uh you know again Jeremy
had just bought himself a nice house and
so we were like and no income and so we
were both a little freaked out so we go
out to Market
and we find a family office and we pitch
this family office on the on what we
want to do and it's exactly this plan
it's exactly this plan
drop a business plan we go in we pitch
it the pitch meeting was was really
quite funny uh because the third person
who's in the triumphant in terms of
running daily wear is a guy named Caleb
Robinson so it's Jeremy Caleb and I are
the majority owners of daily wire so
Caleb at this point was the person
working with the family office and uh
and he's the one who's really interested
in the proposal so he brings us into the
room and we're talking with this family
and as we're talking about the family
they get all sorts of pitches they're
billionaires you know people pitch them
all the time on investments and this guy
at the end of the table turns to me
after I've been going for a while and he
says to me you know we here we get a lot
of pitches on media companies just like
this one what makes you think you're so
special again I got kind of pissed and I
was like I'm better at this than anyone
on the planet I'm better at this than
anyone everyone who's pitched you is
worse at this than I am
and for a second there was like dead
silence in the room and then everybody
started laughing and they they put the
money into the company and so the
initial amount of money they put into
the company it was as an angel investor
was 4.8 million dollars we have never
taken an outside dollar at the company
we did 200 million dollars in Revenue
last year what do you think that
original investment is worth today and I
mean I have ideas uh
I mean
given the splits of the company let's
just say
well into the nine figures unbelievable
now could this have Dawn been done for
less than a million dollars in a
hindsight of you just like bootstrapping
it with Jeremy no I mean because the the
amount we were cash flow positive 18
months in okay so we we had not actively
you know tapped out the money that they
gave us by that point but we were
spending heavily on marketing I don't
know the budgeting I'd have to go back
and look at it I know that our original
expectations of what the company was
going to do and where the revenue was
going to come from from were totally
wrong we've been looking for our uh our
initial pitch for a very long time
because all the places we thought the
revenue was going to come from are the
places it didn't come from and all the
places that we thought it was not going
to come from is where it ended up coming
from so I think our original pitch Had
Me Like My podcast it suggested that
after five years I'd have 200 000
listeners
after like a year I had 200 000
listeners and today we have like a
couple of million listeners so it was
off by like an order of magnitude
um the same thing is true with regard to
subscription so in our original
subscription proposal was like if we're
really lucky we'll get to like 100 000
subscribers after five years we're eight
years in we have a million subscribers
like that was totally and meanwhile
conversely we would thought because this
is the way that the markets worked at
the time and this is just another as I
say if if all of business and many parts
of investment in life are about
diversify and then push where you see
daylight then this is it right like when
we structured the business the internet
was programmatic advertising on websites
this is how you made money right Grudge
made money by having ads on the website
right by made money by having ads on the
website that's where the money was
subscription businesses were still
considered sort of a weird thing I
remember when Rupert shifted Wall Street
journals and subscriptions it was super
controversial at the time people were
like what is he doing he's gonna wreck
his whole audience uh and so our
original business proposal was
advertising on the website will be the
bulk of our Revenue yeah now advertising
on the website represents a a fairly
small part of our Revenue uh as opposed
to Subs which are a large chunk of our
revenue and advertising on my podcast
and the other podcasts that we have on
the network which are a fairly large
chunk of any Commerce which is a fairly
large chunk of our Revenue how many
employees do you have today 260 to 280
yeah I mean we're constantly increasing
yeah and how do you just randomly get in
a room with billionaires because that's
those types of people are extremely
tough to access yes so I mean this is
where knowing people who know people is
really kind of important and putting
yourself in position to know those
people is really important so I always
recommend that people go to places where
there is cross-class pollination this is
why actually Church in synagogue are
really good if you go to a church
there's some very rich people there and
there's some very poor people there and
they have kind of the same idea together
if you if you go to school fundraisers
if you go to charity events if you go to
to you know colloquiums on on various
kind of major issues you're probably
going to meet somebody who knows
somebody but you need to put yourself
out there you need to be in in Social
circumstances so because Jeremy and I
had been in circumstances at charity
dinners involving ourselves in high
level politics pretty much every
connection that you make is going to be
a person referring a person to you so
you have that means that the more people
you touch in your kind of inner circle
that expands your network pretty
radically then you can call them and
what people I think are also afraid of
very often and businesses asking people
for favors they don't understand that's
actually the best way to generate actual
loyalty among people is not to do things
for people it makes people feel that
they're they're it makes people feel bad
if you do if you do somebody a favor
it's a weird trick of human psychology
if you do somebody a favor they actually
feel worse because if if you do them a
favor they feel like they owe you
something and people don't like owing
people things all the time though like
some people like like I live in a
household with four other guys they're
all my roommates I'll do the dishes
someone else's dishes and I feel like it
doesn't go appreciated on occasion well
I mean quite often if it's casual Maybe
not maybe people just ignore it I mean
roommates are a little more casual but
as sort of like in business if somebody
does you a favor you feel bad about it
because now you know you have to repay
the favor yes I mean that's just the way
that it's coming it's a good point yeah
exactly I mean nothing comes for free
and so you you if you put yourself in a
position it weirdly enough it's actually
a kind of cool psychology magical thing
but it's true if you ask somebody in
business for a favor can you connect me
with X Y or Z it makes them feel good
and they very often will do it you think
that and by the way the reason that you
don't want to do it is specifically
because of that right you don't want to
do that because like ah really do I have
to ask that guy for that thing now puts
me in a position of owing him yeah you
have to ask the guy for the thing you
know what he'll probably he'll probably
be happy you did it makes people feel
powerful it makes them feel you you know
useful useful and all of that so you
know asking people to connect you to
other people
it's an easy ask it's one that's easy
for people to accomplish it makes it
gives them a good feeling inside because
they helped you and it also you know if
on sort of the darker human motivation
level it makes them feel that they at
some level have something on you right
they can call back in the favor if they
need to right but before we go on while
we're on the topic of that every
business starts with a strong foundation
and a strong Foundation does not include
complicated spreadsheets and countless
different softwares so if you want to
help restructure your business to be
even better but you don't know where to
start remember these three numbers from
our sponsor netsuite it's thirty six
thousand twenty five and one thirty six
thousand because over 36 000 companies
have already upgraded to netsuite and
stopped wasting time on things like
manual data entry and sifting through
scattered data 25 because netsui has
spent 25 years helping businesses drive
down their costs and one because netsui
is an all-in-one solution that allows
you to manage all of your kpis or key
performance indicators with one
efficient system netsuite can help you
reduce the mistakes in manual data entry
because trust me there's always mistakes
when you're doing something manually and
they can help you scale the business
without all the busy work that comes
alongside with it so get a full picture
of your business and make better
decisions faster download netsuite's
popular kpis checklist right now for
free at netsuite.com ice again that's
netsuite.com ice to get your kpis
checklist again for free netsuite.com
iced link down below and now let's get
back to the episode when you meet higher
level people you must have a specific
ask this is the other thing when you
meet a billionaire and you want to make
a pitch it's got to be very specific it
has to show what they get out of the
deal people tend to pitch broad ideas
and people who you know are being
pitched don't even know what to do with
that so I'll get I'll give you an
example there was a time a long time ago
where this is 2013 maybe I was at a
fundraiser for a local fundraiser for
John McCain and for some of the members
of the so-called Young Guns at that
point that was a gara cancer no longer
in Congress and uh Kevin McCarthy is the
only Young Gun left it's like Paul Ryan
Eric can't or those were the Young Guns
in any case there is fundraiser and this
guy I knew knew Elliot Brody Elliot was
at that point the RNC chair in terms of
uh fundraising he was like the
fundraising chair for for the RNC this
guy knew good friend of mine he was like
you know you're an up-and-comer when you
meet Elliott just ask him for Your
Wildest Dream just ask him for Your
Wildest Dream and I didn't know anything
I'm like okay we go to this fundraiser
it's like poolside in Beverly Hills and
I kind of like go over and he and he
kind of looks at me because he knows I'm
gonna ask him for something and I and I
sit down and he's like so what do you
want and I said okay so here's here's
what I want I want like I need a million
bucks because I want to go and pay for
myself to be syndicated on radio I want
to turn that into a massive data
operation where I have you know a huge
number of followers and then I want to
monetize that for both political and
financial gain and he said like what's
your end goal and at the time I was like
this is 2008 so I was 24. so I was like
and then I'm gonna be president
and he and he's and he looks at me and
he goes
what's wrong with you like what's wrong
with you that's not gonna like that's
not gonna happen and I walked away and I
realized that the mistake that I had
made is that like that's really kind of
a vague plan like it's even though Town
specific it actually is not very
specific if I'd come in and said like
okay let me give you step by step by
step here's how I'm gonna do these
things and I need step one and by the
way not telescope 20 years down the line
when you're saying you're gonna be
president but telescope a year down the
line sure then that is a much better
pitch by the way this is also I've
learned a good pitch when it comes to
public markets when it comes to public
markets the market demands A Five-Year
Plan and nobody actually wants The
Five-Year Plan because you give them The
Five-Year Plan it may be too broad and
then investors are like nah you don't
know how to do that what are you talking
about because you want to be president
is a crazy thing you saying I want a
million dollars because I'm gonna pay
these five specific radio stations to
put me on the air and I'm gonna monetize
that to the tune of X that's it that's a
concrete thing so that's just uh you
know things that you learn along the way
by the way we've completed all of those
steps except for the last so I mean I
will say that I wasn't that far off but
it's it but you know you still have
plans to run for office not until I'm
70. until you're 70. because you can't
be president unless you're an oxygen
area right I mean those are the rules
it's in the Constitution everything I'm
not even 40 man like this by the way you
know again you know what the president
gets paid and I'm having a better year
like Babe Ruth I'm having a better year
than the president so but do you
actually could you see yourself at some
point in the future running for a
president or do you think that you could
potentially have more power and
influence managing the the biggest
conservative Outlet I mean I I do think
the latter meaning listen the
president's most powerful person on the
planet for sure but it's for a
determined period of time within a
constitutional structure in terms of
touching people's lives and and changing
how they think and all of that I think
that you know it's it's very difficult
to think that over the course of the
next 20 30 years I couldn't have more
impact doing what we're doing right now
does the president really have that much
power because my understanding is most
of it is Congress uh the house and the
Senate well I mean
I'll say that I I tend to think that the
legislature unfortunately has become
sort of a vestigial organ of government
it doesn't do a lot other than kick
Omnibus packages over to the executive
who really does kind of all the
implementation and that's becoming more
and more of a problem which is why you
will see executive orders signed by
Obama that will then be rejected by
Trump which will then be rejected again
and reimposed by by Biden the the
president has enormous Global power I
would say in domestic power it's much
more limited than people think it is
globally the foreign policy of the
United States matters an awful awful lot
um in terms of domestic politics yeah
the president has some say but there are
a lot of obstacles in his way I mean Joe
Biden would like to do a lot of things
that he's not actually able to do
because there are states and because
there are checks and balances and
because there are courts on foreign
policy he has plenary power to do
whatever he wants whether it's pulling
out from Afghanistan or whether it's
funding the war in Ukraine you know even
though he needs the legislature to do
that pretty rare that A legislature
denies a wartime president or a
President Who declares a word in Wartime
that the the funding to do that the only
time I can remember that actively
happening is probably near the end of
the war in Vietnam I got an offbeat
question but you married your wife in
two and a half months right are you
proposed yeah we got engaged yeah like
September 5th to December 22nd I was 20
I was 23 when he got engaged and 24 he
got married and she was 20. okay so I'm
24 right now okay so you're not your
horse man there are no prospects they're
not seeing anybody at the moment like
how do you know when the person that
you're seeing is the right person you
say that you can determine this in the
first year and if you can't then there's
something that's wrong I mean I think
that you can determine if it's the wrong
person in the first 10 minutes
right so I think that that's that's
actually real easy determining the wrong
person like that narrows the field quite
considerably
um so the right person
so for me
you're talking about
yeah not to not reduce the Romantic to
business terms I mean there's obvious
things like you have to be sexually
attracted to the person obviously you
have to find them fun to be with are
these like basic preconditions to
wanting to be with the person but those
people tend to think of those as like
the only conditions or is the Key
conditions those are like the get in the
doorway conditions and then there's the
actual conditions for marriage which is
you're signing onto a lifelong
commitment here which is going to be
much harder than you could possibly
imagine because you're going to have
presumably kids and they're an enormous
commitment and you're gonna have
hardships and you're gonna have
tragedies and you're going to have you
know difficulties and they're going to
crop up not like some days they're gonna
crop up most days there will be
something bad that happens on almost
every day of your life and the person
who you are marrying it's a leap of
faith because the person who you who you
know now is not the person who's going
to be there 15 years from now because
people tend to change and people tend to
you know develop habits or their habits
get more ingrained or less ingrained the
nice thing about getting married young
is that you're able to sort of shape
each other a little bit which is nice
when you get married older everybody's
got their baggage everybody's got their
established modes of life and it's kind
of harder to make those match her being
20 and me being 23 when we met it's not
like there were like tons of things that
we were like these are the things but
but the things that we did share were
the unshakable things now this is what
age does that tend to be ingrained like
let's say 35 40 were things people just
get set in their ways I mean no I think
it's way earlier okay I think this is a
huge mistake Society has made I mean I
think frankly people are getting married
too late on average right now I think
it's 28 for men and 26 for women that's
way too late that's way too late I mean
how many people do you know who are who
are 28 and have no ingrained you know
habits or things that they are they're
really kind of used to ways of life
patterns of thinking when things get
like fully fully angry when you stop
changing is really about 70. like you're
gonna change all the way up to one but
but
change in your life is sort of a reverse
exponential curve right I mean like you
changed a lot the younger you are and
then it kind of
diminishing returns right over time so
so The Sweet Spot to get married is
probably as the curve is here right like
before you get to the full diminishing
returns because you can still mold and
adapt to each other and and your habits
don't you think if you're set in your
ways you could find someone else who
blends with that it's harder you're both
you know on the same page I mean it's
definitely harder Yeah the more set in
your ways you are now I will say that
you do want to be set in your values
right so the thing that you need to be
identical are your values or if not
identical very close to identical right
so like for for my wife and for me so my
dad and I quote this all the time he
always says that in order for people to
get married you have to make the
pre-commitment in your mind that you're
ready to get married you don't meet the
person that you want to marry and then
decide you want to get married you
decide you want to get married and then
you meet the person you want to marry
because it's a different headspace it's
a different way of thinking about the
thing it's the difference between saying
I'm going to toss five bucks at a at a
penny stock and saying I'm gonna spend a
hundred thousand dollars investing this
portfolio five dollars in a penny stock
he just toss five dollars a penny stock
who cares you know but but when you're
investing like a full portfolio for a
30-year period you better damn well be
thinking about what exactly your
principles are and so you know in when
it comes to a relationship you ought you
have to be thinking like
what is life going to be like 15 years
from now so we've been married for 15
years now and our life is four children
right and those children rely on us to
be solid and to and to show them what a
good relationship looks like and to be
there for them and even if we're
frustrated to to keep that frustration
within certain boundaries you know
they're relying on that and they're
relying on a solid set of values that
they know that they're going to get the
same answer from Mom and Dad you don't
want your kids value shopping between
Mom and Dad it's a real problem so you
know like our first so knowing that that
meant
that the way that I you know picked my
wife I can't speak for for why she
picked me because who knows but but the
way that the way that I picked my wife
uh was you know effectively I saw a
picture of her I saw she was beautiful
okay we're now past like like very low
bar to get in I I met her and I knew she
was really nice and my sister had also
who fixed us up she she had told me that
she was a very nice person so I knew
that she was like not mean or nasty and
then of course she it turns out she's
the nicest person ever my wife is an
incredibly nice human being which is why
we that's where the contrast one uh so
the and um but like once that was true I
also knew that she was Jewish which was
huge for me because I think that
religious agreement is really important
in marriage uh I knew that she was
Orthodox so now it's an even smaller
group and then within that group it's
like okay what exactly are the things
that are very important to you in terms
of in terms of family what are your
aspirations what kind of what what do
you want your life to look like are you
ambitious ambitious was an important
thing to me are are you a person who's
very committed to the things that you
believe in that's that's really
important to me are we on sort of the
same religious level because even in
Orthodoxy there are gradations as far as
like how how observant you are versus
how non-observing you are and those can
make a really really big difference uh
so every minor gradation is a major
question because you're picking one
person out of all of humanity to spend
the rest of your life with but you can
establish a lot of those things very
quickly by getting a node to a question
you think is vital
I mean there there are girls who I dated
where we I remember there was a a girl I
went on a date with when I was in
Cambridge I had gotten tons of dates
there was one girl I went out with and
you know we were talking and it was very
clear that we had political
disagreements and I she was beautiful
and I was like well you know it was
really nice to meet you and yeah no I
mean like that's but there's a
difference between political
disagreements and value disagreements
right and and which one would come
sometimes so it's so I I it depends so
my wife and I for example on our first
few dates she expressed that she was
more pro-choice than I was she expressed
that she was anti-death penalty and she
expressed that she was kind of squeamish
about guns now because I've been doing
you know this for a long time but by
that point I'd already been doing
politics even when I met her I've been
doing politics semi-professionally for
like six years so I could see that these
were not positions that she was like
ardently committed to right these are
these were not positions where she was
like I saw some weak points in there
well I mean it wasn't it wasn't like she
came in like strong it wasn't like I
said I'm a pro-life person and she was
like what how could you be the pro
that's terrible how could you be a
probably person it was more like well
I'm not sure you're right it was more
like I'm not sure about that you know
some questions and that was like okay so
this is not like a deeply firmly
committed belief on your part again
she's allowed to have her beliefs but if
it had been like a deeply firmly
committed belief that had been very
difficult to get past in the same way
that if we had walked into the first
date and she said you know I have
questions about God I've been like okay
that's all right and if she walks in and
said I hate religion and atheist like
there's certain things where in complete
opposite commitment is going to be a
real problem
um and and so she she didn't seem
particularly political she wasn't uh she
she didn't know who Mitt Romney was
which she still like laughs about that
on her first date I mentioned it she's
like who's Mitt Romney and I found that
kind of charming like I I she is not a
political person like she and I agree
very much on politics now and did pretty
much as soon as she got informed she's I
would say she's more pro-life than I am
now
um but which is almost impossible she
certainly as per life as I am because
I'm not sure that there's a further
extreme but she um is she's not
political she doesn't she doesn't she'll
listen to the show and she has a chance
she doesn't follow the news all that
much and I didn't want that I didn't
want a political marriage like I love
the fact that we got married before I
was famous and that she still does not
care that I meet Senators on the regular
and she doesn't like none of that stuff
is particularly impressive to her and I
find that incredibly charming and
wonderful so my concern is how my
partner is going to respond in specific
circumstances so like let's say tragedy
strikes or let's say she was lied to or
let's say she had a family falling out
or something like that how she responds
to certain circumstances I feel like is
more telling about her personality and
who she is than what she says she so
okay so that that's certainly true the
personality aspects are things that
you're going to have to spend this is
why it's very important to spend a lot
of time with the person I don't mean
over a course of time my wife and I once
we started dating when I say we dated
for three and a half months or three
months whatever people tend to believe
that means that we went on like 12 dates
like you went on a date it was every day
multiple hours a day like once once once
we were once we were past like the first
week I was bringing her dinner every
night like she would be studying for for
her finals or whatever she was a junior
in at UCLA event and I bring her food
and I would just and we would we were
spending hours a day every day by a
month in I said we're never spending a
Shabbat apart so I would like sleep over
at the at the co-op facility where she
lived this Jewish Co-op and sleep in
some other room and then we'd spend all
Shabbat together so you're spending like
lots and lots of time together
um but as you can see are in different
circumstances you do you see people in
different circumstances and that is
definitely important in terms of
personality but again I think that the
the values question is a really big one
because you have to be thinking about
how you build a household
and the blessing that you typically give
at a Jewish wedding is that somebody
should be zoka to build a bison Israel
which which means in very ashkenaz
Hebrew that you should Merit to build a
faithful house in Israel a marriage is
missional it's not just a contract it's
a mission so what does that mission look
like what are the end goals of that
mission and then you have to orient your
values toward what the end goals of that
mission are so you know their marriage
is where the mission is just to have a
good time and go on vacation okay well
if that's your central value then that's
your central value for us our Central
value is how do we raise Jewish Orthodox
moral kids
okay that means we have that's like
several things in a row there right
Jewish which means I have to marry
inside the religion Orthodox which means
a certain level of practice and moral
which means we have to have certain
agreements on on virtue and and ethics
we went for like a it was a three-hour
date like we went and we started at like
I don't know three o'clock in the
afternoon and we wrapped it up around
six o'clock in the evening and we we
walked and we talked about like Free
Will and determinism these are like
issues on date number one and you can
ask my wife like that like day number
two was like death penalty and gun
control get into that like like you
meter you're just like hey what are your
thoughts on determinism
yeah weed them through you know yeah
exactly yeah you gotta run them through
the paces
it was more like you know you get past
hobbies and it's nice to meet you and
and then you know the conversation flows
or it doesn't
and it kind of yeah I mean it was it was
it wasn't like I was quizzing her on it
it was more like
you know here's some stuff that I'm I
think I said I was I was writing on
something you said what are you writing
on and I'm like yeah exactly here's what
I'm writing on and then that turned into
like and then as we were getting out of
the car before before she got out of the
car before I dropped her back off uh I
said to her
um I don't hold by like any of this you
know three-day nonsense where I'm gonna
you know make you feel was like insecure
like are we going on a second date I
would like to go on a second date with
you so if so name me a time and date
and she and she did and the rest is
history like from her side it's kind of
funny because yeah I drove up so after
after law school I was like I'm a lawyer
I'm a lawyer in La I'm gonna get a car
so I gotta so my first car had been a
1986 Honda Civic with no air
conditioning that in my family was sort
of a hand-me-down it started with me we
bought it for 400 it went to my sister
eventually became known as trustee Rusty
and uh and and my second car was a 2006
a 2006 Mustang GT convertible uh which
was baby blue and I drove up and the way
my wife tells it she I drove up and
she's like who is this and then
I got out and I was wearing like I
didn't know how to dress at all and
those I still really don't and I have
people who give me clothes to wear um
but I I no I know I think a little bit
more but that's after years of prep at
that time like my idea of a nice outfit
was like a faded polo shirt that was at
least a size too big and some like Dad
jeans and so I get out and I look like a
complete nerd and if you look at
pictures of me in those days like my
hair now is at least somewhat okay but
my wife saw that and she's like oh no
he's just a nerd that's good and so like
she it's not like the girl who takes off
or the guy the girl who wears glasses
the guy just takes off the glasses like
there you go yeah exactly I saw that
yeah yeah what you really saw is like
the opposite right it was like it was
like it was like oh he's driving up all
cool and boss and but what a jerky so
who drives that car and then I get on
him like a super nerdy guy and she's
like okay okay it'll be fine we're did
you budge in the relationship how did
she change you for the better I'm famous
for not having feelings I do have
feelings but pretty much only about my
family like if you saw me in context
with my kids
I am a I'm a warm ball of mush with my
kids and with my wife like I'm I'm a
really really committed father and
husband like that is my thing and I go
out of my way for my wife in
extraordinary ways and for my kids in
extraordinary ways
um and uh so that's like I never cried
in a movie before I got married right
then you cry at movies and and then when
you see your kids it completely changes
everything the way that I've expressed
it before is that basically I think it's
true for everyone but it's particularly
true for me that basically your range of
emotion when you're single is like 10 on
the upper end and zero on the lower end
then you get married and goes to like 20
on the upper end because when you're
with your partner and it's really happy
it's phenomenal and like negative 20
because if you're at odds or if
something bad is happening in your
partner it's the worst thing in the
world and then you have kids and all
limits are completely removed like by
far the worst things that happen are
with your kids they're like my my
daughter my oldest daughter for example
she had open heart surgery when she was
a year and a half like though like
horrendous
um and it's like the worst things that
happen but the best things that happen
are like three days ago I've got all
I've got all four of my kids they're on
one room and the baby is little he's
like two months old and the and my
three-year-old daughter is is having her
hair brushed by her older sister while
my son reads who's seven is reading them
a book and like that stuff it's it's
amazing but when the kids are being
jerks it's really awful like this so all
limits are removed so what she I I would
say that she also taught me that
communication can be different to
different people so yeah I can knew that
before but it certainly matures you
because being married means that you
can't communicate to your wife in the
same way that I would communicate to
other people like if we get into debate
like early on in our in our marriage if
I would start like getting into America
should be like stop going into debate
mode you need to stop it right now
because you can't talk to your wife the
same way that I would talk to somebody
on a podcast it's ridiculous you can't
do that
I mean sure I could destroy my wife with
facts and logic but like what's it like
what what exactly how is that going to
redound to either of our benefits like
again my favorite phrase in marriages
would you rather be writer would rather
be happy because those are the choices
my friends like you cannot be both right
and happy all the time wise words you're
just gonna have to you're just gonna
have to suck it up when do you suck it
up though when you know like hey this is
where I'm going to explain my point and
here's where I'm gonna suck it up um so
so I am very lucky in the fact that if I
if I tell my wife that something is
deeply bothering me about something that
she's doing she will she will move like
she's very malleable that way
um which is an amazing quality that not
a lot of people have male or female
um but I mean there are certain things
where like
to give a very common example my wife is
not good with time like and not only is
she not good at the time she doesn't
know that she's not good with time so
that means that you know if I tell her
that we need to leave at a given point
and it doesn't happen I now have two
choices one is I can either like be
angry and get mad at her about it or I
can lecture her about it and then I will
be miserable and also she will be
miserable
or I can just know going in we're
probably gonna be late I can kind of
take a breath be like okay this is
annoying to me and I'm sure there are
things that I know there are things
about me that where it's where it's the
same thing for for years for her it was
that if I'm reading I cannot be I cannot
be bothered and I don't mean like
she can't you know come in interrupt me
I mean I literally can't hear it if if
I'm reading my concentration is so great
that people can be talking directly in
my ear and I don't hear it I didn't
realize this until I had my
nine-year-old daughter my nine-year-old
daughter is exactly the same way I have
to I have to call her like five times to
get her to take her nose out of a book
if she if she's reading so I'm sure
that's that point of like high
irritation for my wife but that's just
the way it is and so she's gonna you
know like she it's annoying it'll
continue to be annoying no it's it's
situations like that you know little
things that you let go because to not
let them go would be stupid and Petty
right and yeah they're super annoying
like again my wife has a thousand things
about me that are that I'm sure are
incredibly irritating
you know my wife loses her phone all the
time we joke all the time that as soon
as you know the technology is available
I'm gonna trip her like a cat like we're
gonna put the phone in her so that she
never loses her phone again but am I
gonna get like ticked off every time she
loses her phone that's going to be a
really bad thing uh so you it's it's
more stuff like it's more if something
is deeply bothering you with your spouse
then you have to sit down and have like
a real conversation you know when it
comes to little things you most of most
of relationships is is a lot of
relationships is letting those things go
which makes you a more patient human and
it really is much more applicable with
your kids than your spouse all that
stuff is way worse with your kids than
your spouse I love that quote about the
range of emotions that you feel through
different stages of life I've actually
quoted that before on this podcast and
it just uh I just told me that before I
told him that before I really hope that
that does prove to be the case when I do
end up finding a spouse and then end up
having kids because that sounds that
sounds really nice actually it's
something that sounds it's amazing and
it sucks all at the same time I mean
like I always like to present you know
the full panoply I'm not gonna pretend
that every moment with my kids is a joy
in fact when we had the fourth I sat
there and I calculated out the odds that
all four of them were going to be good
at any one time which are 1 and 16 right
because it's one half to the fourth
power so it's like because at any given
time there's a 50 shot they'll be good
or bad and so all four of them being
good at one time it's like one out of
16. now the good news is all four of
them are only bad one out of 16 times
but most of the time at least one or two
of them are being a problem you know
that it's really rough I mean like when
kids are being bad when they're being
jackasses it's really really tough and
they are I mean they're really they can
be really annoying and time consuming
and then again there's nothing better in
the entire world than when your kids are
giving a hug there's not there's nothing
better than that it is the best thing in
the entire world now I'm curious how you
prioritize and budget your time between
raising a family but also running a
business and going through the startup
because I know what that could be like
and that's completely consuming and
sometimes that has to be the priority
yeah so I will say that yeah this is
this is really why I think that
it's important to start Young on a lot
of these things so the the I didn't have
kids until I was 30 right so I was
married at 24 but we didn't have kids
for the first six years so by the time
we had kids already we had launched
daily we we launched daily wire let's
see I had one kid by the time we
launched anywhere
um shoot but she was very little and my
wife is the one who really had it hard
my wife was in medical school at the
time so she was in medical school all
the way through our first two and she
was still finishing residency pregnant
with our third so that was really rough
for her like
basically for me it was always
priorities my kids always come first
always always always always so that
means that if if there is an emergency
then my kids come first I I'm I think
it's really important I've talked about
this a lot to have a support structure
that's not just you and your wife really
really important so I we we purposefully
located like a mile from my parents we
lived a mile from my parents our entire
marriage you know we purposefully put
ourselves in a situation where if we
need help we can call somebody and they
can come over and my dad can come over
my mom can come over they'll watch the
kids uh which is really really important
this is why I say the community you
choose to live is is vital being part of
a church or a synagogue it's great
because it immediately gives you
connections with other people who are
capable of helping you out if you need
um it does take more than just you and
your wife otherwise it gets very
overwhelming very quickly
um especially you know we're lucky we
can afford a nanny but a lot of people
can't and we we didn't have one for you
know a while so the
you know I think that when it comes to
the prioritization I can tell you my
schedule now that I can tell you you
know how we sort of did it well we were
starting the company starting the
company is a lot harder as you say the
hours were insane
they're irregular uh you you work a lot
of Sundays
um that's that's very hard the kids were
very little at the time so that made it
a little easier because a two-year-old
doesn't care so much
um I as I said my wife's in residency
and I would literally like take our just
so that you could see the kids like for
15 minutes a day I would pick I'd take
them in the car I'd Drive 45 minutes to
her in the car with the kids she'd walk
out she'd eat dinner in the car while
visiting with the kids she'd go back in
I'd drive home with the kids I'd put
them to bed my day now my kids don't
know I have a job right because that was
my priority so it remains my priority so
the way that this basically works I wake
up my kids wake me up every morning at
like 6 a.m and I get up and I make
breakfast for them I get them dressed I
get them ready for the day
um meanwhile I might be like just
perusing the news on my phone to see if
I have to supplement for the show I
leave the house at like 7 45 because
that's basically when they leave the
house for school
I go into the to the show I I film the
show I film extras I do phone calls I
try to work out I try to get everything
done between the Windows 7 45 AM and 3
30 p.m which is when they get out from
school very often I'm the one who picks
them up from school I do not work from
the time I pick them up from school to
the time they go to bed which right now
is about 7 30. so that four hour period
I'm basically at their disposal they're
exceptions I mean there's times when
I'll have a business call and I'll have
my dad come over or the nanny watches
them or my wife you know my wife doesn't
have to work if she doesn't want to now
so she so she you know picks up a lot of
that slack but my goal is that basically
between 3 30 and 7 30 I'm almost
entirely at their disposal they go to
bed I start working again I pick up the
phone I make a few phone calls I do what
I need to do if there's an emergency
people can get a hold of me but I tend
to be very terse both on the phone and
an email so that's so I again doing
things quickly is very helpful but
segmenting the time like that means that
my kids they're not even aware that like
they get when I go on a business trip
for one night they get like upset they
where are you going or if I have work on
if I don't get home from work until five
they're like What's Happening why is it
why is this happening right now I'm
lucky I've been able to construct my
life around that yeah it wasn't always
like that but is it difficult for you to
Outsource that because I feel like
you're very much like you want things
done they have to be correct they have
to be in order how is that Outsourcing
to other people and trusting them to do
it to yourself with regard to the
company you mean well yeah yeah I mean
with regard to the company
um
so my view on hiring and firing so I
don't do the hiring and firing at Daily
wire right Jeremy really is more
responsible Caleb is really more
responsible for that I I you know I have
like a say into who's working on my show
and if I think somebody's doing a crappy
job I'll stand off about it but I'm not
the person who's in the interview
meetings but with that said my general
view of hiring and firing is that
the entire if you have to fire somebody
it's because it's your mistake not
theirs almost always uh it was your
mistake in putting them in a position
where they were not going to succeed I I
think that very often employers will try
to cram a square block into into a round
hole uh or they'll say you know I wish
that this person wore a thing just like
dating just like any other business
relationship you got to take people for
what they are and so the the the hard
part and then you have to let them be
free to do the thing you have to give
them enough Authority and enough
responsibility that they can do the
thing and they can take care of a thing
but enough responsibility if the thing
goes wrong they also get held
accountable for that which means you
have to give people clear metrics of
success you can't just be like do a
thing it has to be and here's what I
wanted to look like in kind of General
outline and you have to hit this Mark
have you noticed that Mark I that's fine
but you need to explain to me why you
didn't hit that Mark and usually five
rings occur because either bad direction
from above they didn't give people
metrics to hit or the metrics they gave
were too vague or bad direction or
micromanagement people inserting
themselves too much into the process and
not letting the person take ownership of
the thing because people who work all
want to take ownership of of what they
do and then finally you really have to
be able to suss out this is another one
of kind of the sayings that we have a
daily wire is that uh you you can't
teach you can't teach effort you can't
if if people want it they want it and if
they don't want it
they don't they don't want it and you
can't make somebody into a person who
has effort into a person who wants it as
much as there are lots of talented
people and they just don't who don't
want it enough I'd much rather have the
person who's like gonna do the grunt
work who wants it like the aggressive
I'd rather have that person who's
slightly less talented than the person
who's more talented and doesn't have the
the gumption we just had Papa John uh
Schneider on the podcast and he had a
great quote on that he said hire for
attitude and train for aptitude I think
I think that's right I think that's
right as long as you have like a central
silk as long as you have like the
ability to be molded that's 100 True
which is why I've advocated for a long
time that I think that you know I'd
rather hire a bunch of kids at a high
school who have 1450 SATs and no college
degree then a bunch of kids of the
college degree who have been told that
you know they are owed 150 000 a year
for finger painting if you give me like
raw talent and Grit and much much rather
have that than than you know somebody
who's even been working in the field for
20 years I'm a big fan of
apprenticeships I think first of all
virtually nobody learns how to do a job
at going to school I think virtually
everybody learns how to do a job by
doing the job and doing it a lot and
doing it many many times like my number
one piece of advice for people who want
to get into my industry is do a bunch of
stuff for free that's right that's what
I always say that's what we both did
that's what Jack did so Jack sent me
seven emails over the Span in maybe
eight months and said I want to come
work with you I'll do anything you want
to follow it up you don't have to pay me
I just want to work give me something to
do please give me something to do please
monthly it was almost a year later I
said okay fine you want to hear some
busy work for you to do you finished it
in like two days yeah and it was like 18
hours of work he's like give me more
yeah right awesome that's so many
different things I mean my mom was very
much like that my mom started off as a
secretary she had an ed degree from from
Boston University and she started off as
a secretary at a film and TV company
because there was an opening in the
paper and she ended up as as vice
president of the company because that's
what she would do it was just like get
in and grind just grind and learn how to
do the thing and get good at the thing
now let me ask you this what do you
think of unpaid internships I think that
unpaid internships are vital
I think this nonsense about how you pay
interns is garbage I mean I understand
that's the legal standard now and so I
will never say anything that puts us in
legal Jeopardy here's daily wire we
comply with all legal restrictions
requirements and obligations but with
that said unpaid internships are
absolutely vital because why the hell
would I pay an intern
for a job when I can get a college
graduate with a year of experience to do
that job for the same pay all you're
doing is depriving people of the
opportunity to actually get good at the
thing you're expecting people to start
off at a level of good it's really
really stupid it's really stupid I took
in unpaid internships over and over and
over again I was in an unpaid intern to
ad firm it was great it taught me how to
how to you know
right as an in pithy fashion again I
took a job for one-third of the pay that
I normally would make because you need
to get good at the thing this is another
one of my recommendations for people who
are trying to you know break in and
they're aggressive is there is no job
that is below you you you like if you
think there's a job below you that that
is wrong when this company started
starting Jeremy boring's pool house and
on weekends I would go into the office
and I would see Caleb Robinson in the
back room with Jeremy boring's brother
nailing planks to a giant piece of wood
and that was going to be the background
of my set like we just got a five
million dollar infusion Caleb is in the
back room with a hammer and nails and
wood and he's just nailing wood wood and
that that was like that's the background
that you see on the first step of the
first episode you say about the argument
that the opportunities go to people who
can financially support themselves or
have the the the background like for you
for example yeah you could afford to do
that because you could live with your
parents you could have something to fall
back on people who need something to
survive so I mean I I think that that's
true but I think that they're misreading
how the markets work I mean like I think
that that is a good piece of
compassionate talk and I think it has
precisely the opposite effects of what
it seeks to achieve you're saying okay
well if if all the internships are paid
then okay but who do you think is going
to get the paid internships then do you
think it's going to be the poor kid or
do you think it's going to be the
slightly richer kid
well why would it be the poor kid
is that like the the actual answer to
that is that the only way that you're
going to to find a way in is by being
competitive
in the marketplace and it doesn't make
you more competitive
for them to have to pay more I mean this
is actually the predictable side effect
of minimum wage minimum wage is removed
virtually all teen employment in the
United States the teen unemployment rate
in the United States nobody looks at it
but like the the unemployment rate at
age of 16 which used to be much much
much lower is now much much higher why
because of minimum wage because why
would you pay a 16 year old minimum wage
when I can pay a 19 year old minimum
wage or a 20 year old minimum wage when
you artificially raise the the the cost
of Labor people are going to
artificially seek people to do those
jobs who have credentials that they
wouldn't necessarily need I mean you'll
now see people who are suggesting that
you have to have a college to agree to
be a barista at Starbucks why because
you're paying that person 25 an hour
like that that's that's a serious
problem that's not going to get cured by
this piece of like you can point out the
problem and maybe it remains a problem
with it I'm not saying it's not a
problem with unpaid internship I'm just
saying that the policy recommendation
that is being made to cure that which is
to mandate pay for unpaid interns does
not cure the problem it exacerbates the
problem it means I'm just not going to
have any why would I have a paid intern
why don't you hire an employee it's a
pain in the ass like there's a it
creates all sorts of legal obligations
it's it's it's really foolish and
especially because
there there is a point like we're
assuming that every unpaid intern is 19
or 20 years old or 18 like that you're
supporting yourself you're trying to get
through college try and go all that
stuff I don't know when you guys had
your first kind of job or your first
internship your first apprenticeship but
I had someone I was like 13 or 14 years
old me too I mean that that was not like
amazing jobs but I remember working an
entire year at like the public middle
school I went in like the student store
making 25 about 25 an hour so that I
could eventually buy a clock from my
parents or something like I remember
doing that sort of stuff like again this
all sounds like oh you know rich people
talking about things that they could
never understand if they if they were
poor but the reality is that every rich
person not every virtually every rich
person I know started off not as a rich
person
not as a rich person Jeremy's family is
poor or at least lower middle class
Caleb's family from what I understand
was not a Caleb was certainly Caleb is
like a high school grad Jeremy dropped
out of college like these are these are
not families that like where you're
talking about massive wealth and again
even my family and the assumption is
because I'm an orthodox Jew and because
I went to Harvard that I must have like
tremendous family wealth or something
again I grew up in a in the same bedroom
as my three younger sisters with one
bathroom for six people until I was 11
years old that doesn't make me poor that
certainly that made me Rich so like the
the rules that I'm saying are not about
rich people not understanding it's it's
about look at the people who are rich
and then ask them how they got to be
that way right that's the question that
nobody wants to ask is how do the rich
people get to be rich not
how do we you know do you have sympathy
for the person who's poor I had so I
have such sympathy for people who are
poor that I want them to be rich here
are the steps that are required to be
rich and if you see that as talking down
to people I I don't know how it's
talking down to people as opposed to
saying this is how you get here I want
everybody to be up here what would you
say the steps are if you were to
simplify I mean they're they're very
basic ones you got to finish High School
you don't have babies before you get
married uh you have to get a job if you
do those three things you will not be
permanently poor in the United States by
all available metrics and evidence
that's the first step then to actually
get rich you have to develop a skill set
and you have to develop a skill set that
people want from you I've always said
that the the that wealth in terms of
like broad overview lies at the Nexus of
three things and there's some pretty
good business evidence to support this
uh that allows the next things that you
are good at things that people want from
you and things that you're passionate
about there are a lot of things that
you're good at you're not passionate
about it's gonna be hard for you to do
those for long periods of time that a
lot of things that you're passionate
about that you suck at there's no money
there there are a lot of things that
you're passionate about you're good at
and that no one else cares about and
that's not gonna make any money either
what you need is the Nexus of those
three things and that sweet spot is
where is where the money is for you and
that can be in virtually anything it
really can be because this is a giant
country and it's a huge International
economy and there are Niche markets in
pretty much everything I know people who
are loaded as plumbers I know people
like I know people who have made an
enormous amount of money like tons of
money by starting like cell phone kiosks
at the at the mall yeah like sure like
that's I I know one person a particular
good friend of mine he literally sold
the company for hundreds of millions of
dollars he started off by selling like
cell phones at a kiosk in the mall I
mean like this you can do these things
but you have to find that in Access and
you have to be passionate about it and
then you have to like really sacrifice
for it I'm curious on the mission
statement of the daily wire is the goal
to hopefully change the opinions of the
political adversaries maybe the people
that don't necessarily agree with your
philosophies to get in more with your
moral standards and philosophies and
political leanings and stuff like that
so everyone kind of believes more so
what you believe to be the ethical
standard I mean listen ideally I'd love
to convince everybody that I'm right
that would be wonderful but I think that
the reality of life is that like any
Market they're the people who are
implacably opposed to you you're not
going to be able to allow that
there are people who are apathetic you
may be able to convince some of those
people to come along they're people who
are sort of in the middle and looking at
both sides those are the people who I
hope I'm really aiming at and then
there's your base which are people who
already agree with you so like three out
of those four kind of contentions are
available to me the people who are
implacably opposed like to the point
where they think I'm Hitler or that they
think that I'm the root of all evil in
the universe I'm not worried about
convincing those people because
they don't they're nothing's going to
change there I'm not banging my head
against a wall I say this all the time
people ask me like what about this
cousin who you know argues X Y and Z and
it makes me so mad and I always ask them
like what's the purpose of a
conversation start with that what are
you seeking to achieve in the
conversation and again it sounds very
cold and clinical that way but the truth
is that you can think about most
conversations in life that way and if
you start thinking about even personal
conversations that way sometimes it's
really really useful I remember that
I've told the story a thousand times but
it's it's good marriage story you know
my wife would ask me for years she would
come and she'd complain about a thing
and I would make the mistake of trying
to solve the thing and she'd get mad at
me because she doesn't want the thing
solved what she wanted was sympathy what
she wanted was a a kind ear to listen to
the thing which as you might expect is
not my easiest thing and uh and so at a
certain point I said to her listen I
need you to do me a favor I don't speak
this language so I'm gonna need you do
me a favor when you start saying a thing
that's bad is this a Solutions
conversation or is this a sympathy
conversation I'm just gonna need to ask
that not because I'm being jerk but
because I actually want to know so that
we don't keep running into this so
she'll tell me like she's good about
this I'll say to her like do you want do
you want me to like provide Solutions
here because I'm happy to to Blue Sky
this thing or do you want me to or do
you want to talk about you know like how
this makes you feel we can we can do
that too but I just need to know which
one of these things it is because I'm
not good at reading this and um and I
feel like that that was very productive
that's true for a huge number of
conversations and it's true politically
as well this is why when people say well
how do you debate it depends is it a
debate is it a discussion who's the
audience what is the end goal here and
there are certain debates like public
debates where it's not a discussion the
person isn't open-minded it's just an
attempt to establish Clarity of the
point of view and that's where you get
you know the Rex kind of moments like
Ben Shapiro rex or something
um but but that doesn't mean you have to
be rude or mean or something it just
means that you have to you know go in
knowing that it's gonna be oppositional
that's a very different thing because
you're not talking to this person you're
talking to these people out here right
this is a different thing then there's
you're talking to the crowd which is a
speech and there you try to actually
convince hopefully uh and then there are
conversations with people who disagree
where it's both you're trying to clarify
and convince and maybe change your own
point of view those are the
conversations I enjoy the best and those
are actually the ones I do the most the
most just in terms of the time spent
if there's one area where I feel like uh
the show and what we do with the daily
wire is underappreciated it's that and
we have on more guests I personally have
one more guests who disagree with me
than I think anyone else in political
talk probably
um yeah I've had on people who are who
are rabbit atheists and we have very
wide-ranging and I think coaching
conversations I'll have on people who
are who are socialists and we'll have
wide-ranging and coaching conversations
like that like I like doing that kind of
stuff but that's a different
conversation than the person who comes
in ready to swing at you it does seem as
though the right in general has become a
lot trendier or I I feel like social
media is is beginning to steer in that
direction why do you think that is
because counter-cultural so for a long
time in this country the right was the
culture and then the left was The
Counter Culture and so all the kids were
like ah The Counter Culture and now the
Counter Culture has become a culture a
Traditional Values have become something
that you have to whisper to your friends
about
right to say that for example
heterosexual marriage is more societally
valuable than homosexual marriage which
was inarguable for literally all of
human history and by the way on a
utilitarian level remains inarguable
today to say that sort of stuff
everybody cringes everybody couldn't
accept for all the people who don't who
are like that actually is true and I
can't believe that people are saying
that and when you're like 15 16 years
old there's something very attractive
about people saying things that's true
especially if you've been told that
you're not allowed to say it now it's
easy to mix that up and this is one of
the problems that you see on the right
sometimes it's easy to mix that up with
just
being oppositional for the sake of being
oppositional so there's a difference
between saying things are true I've said
this before there's a difference in
offending people by saying things that
are true and offending people because
you're being adjourned that's not quite
the same thing and I think that the
right I think everybody has a tendency
because human beings are reactionary to
be like oh it pisses it pisses those
guys off it must be amazing and so it
makes it difficult to distinguish
between people who are saying things
that are untrue but piss that side off
and people who are saying things that
are true and well thought out and piss
that side off but if you no I try to be
good enough at my job and moral enough
as a human being to not say things just
to piss people off when I say when I say
may take people off may it does I mean
but and and some of it is is trollery I
mean like burning Barbies is trollery
obviously
um but but by the same like I don't make
a habit of it although I was asked that
that YouTube video made a lot of money
actually and I was asked by some people
at the company what we were going to do
with that money and I said well you know
just like any other business proposition
you keep doubling down we're gonna buy
800 more Barbies and we're going to burn
them for me it was very
um memorable
oh my God I can't believe you did that
okay you guys you spent like 400 million
dollars to make a movie about giant
dolls and you're like how much money did
you spend to burn four Barbies I promise
you our budgeting was perfectly in line
it was fine they come up with ideas like
that because the other one that really
started yeah honest to God like all that
was was it was it's barberheimer I'm
holding a bomb we throw the bomb and
when we realized we didn't have the
capacity in time to make a good
explosion
graphic that's all it was we didn't have
the capacity to actually like make a
nuke graphic that would look really cool
and and like
Terminator 2 of the Barbies right we
didn't have that so instead I'm holding
a bomb and then I'm holding a match and
then I like the Mansion I set them on
fire and that's like because it costs
zero money and zero time that's why
because the turnaround time between when
I filmed that and when it went up was
one day that's why what about like the
whop breakdown because that was another
yeah and it really stood out okay so the
watt breakdown what's so funny about
that is that so there's this strange
Dynamic that has cropped up in the last
few years where I'm I will make I will I
will do something that is clearly meant
to be funny like that is clearly a joke
and then the left will be like does he
even know he's joking it's like yeah no
I know I'm joking I'm of course I'm
joking I mean I did a 15 minute
Exposition on the dumbest song ever
written of course I know I'm joking but
then they'll be like is he really joking
but is he is like what yeah I am and
undertones but the undertones oh I mean
first of all I will admit that there's
an undertone to these videos of moral
condemnation because yes it is bad that
we have a culture that glorifies songs
that talk about the moisture shade of
your genitals that's a bad thing that's
not good for kids it's directed it's
directed at teenagers it's directed at
young girls it's stupid it's venal it's
it's so yes am I condemnatory of that
sure also is it funny that I'm out I a
very white person I'm reading slowly and
purposefully bleeping out the words to
of course that's funny by the way
I've been doing that routine since like
2014. I used to do it on on my Seattle
radio show except they used to pull
handles water music and I used to put it
underneath
and we play that underneath me reading
rap lyrics because the whole idea is
that this is a degraded culture and now
I'm going to place this again some of
the great pieces in the western Canon
and you're going to see how stupid this
is so yeah I mean it's it was it we had
a graphic at the beginning of it it's
called deconstructing the culture I've
been doing it for years but every so
often one of them will just blow up yeah
and you can have two attitudes about it
one is to be like annoying the other
it's like I'm kind of delighted that
people you know are are made so
both angry and happy by you by something
poking the bear a little bit like let me
know we certainly know we certainly know
when we make a Barbie
review so there are certain things in
culture that have become sacrosanct and
you're not allowed to say them like
Beyonce is overrated she's overrated or
like Barbie is an unfunny movie that is
filled with feminist claptrap it's an
unfunny movie that's filled with
feminist claptrap or like cardi B is an
untalented hack who's been elevated to a
position of extraordinary cultural Power
by the fact that she's incredibly vulgar
everything I just said so if you say if
you say these things you're really not
supposed to say them and so yeah I mean
there I am poking a stick in the eye
because
how is it that those things are
unsayable that's the thing that always
gets me I talk about politics and
morality and I say things that are
really Politically Incorrect all the
time and every time in the last several
years there's been like a massive blow
up it's not about any of those things
it's about a cultural icon that the left
has erected and then I've said I don't
like that thing it's bad my Beyonce's
overrated no I mean I said in my video
about the follow-up to the Barbie video
and the internet treated me burning the
Barbies like I had burned a Quran or
something I mean like it actually was
like holy writ this is how seriously
people take their culture first of all
you shouldn't take culture that
seriously because our culture is
fundamentally unserious I guess he's
taking Bach that seriously seriously
don't tell me I have to take Nicki Minaj
that seriously please like please like
spare me I'm a cultural snob I will
remain a cultural snob because there are
standards of beauty and good in this
world and Beethoven is better than cardi
B and Brahms is better than Nicki Minaj
and Shakespeare is better than both of
them and trying to pretend that all of
these things are flat you know a
flattened version of culture that all
culture is equivalent is stupid and it's
pure Isle and it's deadening to the
human soul and when you post pictures of
you on Twitter outside the Barbie poster
holding a little we had no idea I was
gonna go viral no no no no no
this is one of the funniest
it didn't occur to us because it we
literally did that in the spur of the
moment so we went at like 11 o'clock in
the morning to this dumb piece of trash
and I and I I go and I I was just
wearing what I had worn on the show that
day right I mean on the show that day I
just worn you know normal people clothes
like a black T-shirt and black I I how
many people across the United States on
a given day were black a black T-shirt
and black jeans that sounds like a
pretty common outfit yeah okay that
wasn't like I'm clearly making fun of
the Barbie movie I'm wearing a denim
jacket and a white shirt right like
clearly that is like no one owns a denim
jacket anymore it's not 1985 but like a
black T-shirt and black jeans is pretty
much like my normal go-to wear so in any
case we go and I'm like taking notes in
the back and my producers are are
cynically slow clapping all of the uh
America Ferrera speeches and everything
and uh and then we come out and right
before we leave they're like you know
we're gonna have to like push this video
out and we're gonna put a tweet out
about it do you want to take a picture
and should we take a picture in front of
the giant Barbie poster and I was like
well I mean it yeah sure I mean we're
doing memes anyway so like why not so
I'm like there and I'm not gonna be like
smiling because I hated the movie and
I'm not gonna be like really grumpy
because it didn't make me like super
grumpy as much as just annoyed that I
wasted two hours of my life doing this
and so I'm just kind of like
slightly annoyed and I'm holding a pad
of paper because I wanted to show people
that yeah like there is something funny
about the fact that I sat there and I
like literally took notes but helps you
do a review I mean if you're reviewing a
movie this is how you do a review you go
in with a pattern you think that the
reviewer at the Wall Street Journal is
sitting there without a pad of paper
when he's watching a movie how's he
gonna review the movie he's got to write
down quotes like this is so it's so the
fact that that went like super duper
viral and people were very upset about
it oh my God he took a picture in front
of the Barbie poster oh no okay Rich you
want to talk first world problems you
being upset about me standing in front
of a Barbie poster at a theater that's
that's a first world problem gonna call
me an elite you're gonna leave I think
because people knew what was coming of
course
that I thought it was trash yeah I mean
it was it like that tweet had maybe more
traffic than the actual video it
probably did I mean do we know I feel
like it was cool on every single
platform like tens of like people were
nuts about the tweet all I said is that
it's a woke piece of crap and everyone
was like no it was like slow motion no
it was like William Defoe getting shot
from behind in platoon
guys get over it I'm allowed to think
that you're your beloved movie about the
joys of feminism is garbage
I'm sorry it wasn't Citizen Kane
that's your problem I didn't make it and
when you get hate
what's crazy to me is that that picture
how many views does what does a woman
have on Twitter because I saw it when it
was at I think 30 40 million I think 200
million so the fact that one picture got
a fourth of what this documentary got is
I really think I mean Twitter metrics
are a little bit weird
scrolling pass also it's easier to
consume a picture than it is to Consumer
full movie but it's uh but yeah I mean
of all the things that I've tweeted do I
think that that one deserves to be like
Far and Away number one I have serious
doubts about the wisdom of the American
public if that's the case but you know
but isn't that proof that you really
have to dumb things down for most people
and most platforms
the the simpler it is to consume the
better it is well the more entertaining
it is to consume the better it is really
something about dumbing down it's about
entertaining it down
and so what I take some pride in is the
fact that even when I talk about
politics I hope that it's both
informative and entertaining so if I'm
doing a full breakdown of the indictment
against Trump this week then you know I
hope that I'm going to give you all the
information you need to know from a
legal point of view and from a political
point of view but I hope that there will
be a few jokes along the way and you'll
find it entertaining it's a lot easier
to do that about entertainment I mean we
did a video about me reviewing
Oppenheimer it did pretty big traffic
like two days ago like people like
talking about entertainment specifically
because it's light that's why the and
that's why the juxtaposition of me being
kind of seriously considering the
message of Barbie is inherently funny
but it actually is so on one level it's
funny because obviously it's funny me
talking about like the the clear
narrative implications of a movie about
a doll that's funny but also the entire
media did make it about that the
importance of the Barbie why was the why
was the Barbie movie significantly more
important than the latest Paddington
film
why I mean they're they're both about
children's toys so why is one of them in
in in in insanely important cultural
event that the Press is going Gaga over
and there's big articles like I read
them in advance they're huge articles
like Vanity Fair talking with Greta
Gerwig and talking with Margot Robbie
and talking about their perspectives on
feminism and talking with the Trans
person who's in the who's in the movie
and all the rest of it because they take
the politics very seriously but they
don't like is that I noticed that they
take the politics very seriously and I
think their politics are garbage that's
the thing they don't like what they want
is to be able to promote the propaganda
without anybody pointing out that it is
propaganda and so the way they treat
that is that how dare you take this
seriously oh it's such a joke that you
take this seriously that's why the view
is doing that routine The View did this
routine we're like oh my God isn't it
emasculating that you took this movie
seriously you took the movie seriously I
noticed that you took the movie
seriously you started it I mean like and
and as far as it being emasculating
again the the it is amazing to me how
quickly
members of the cultural left will jump
to such transphobic Notions as
emasculation it's just it makes me very
upset how dare they maybe I was just in
touch with my feminine side I'm a man I
can be or maybe I'm a woman who knows
I'm curious uh how you the amount of
hate that you get because you get an
inordinate amount of hate I mean it's
ridiculous I can bring up an example
okay this is kind of embarrassing but I
feel a little bit of Shame when I say
that I love Ben Shapiro I really do I
mean I've I've watched you for like nine
years I saw you in high school right
like speaking at a college campus I I
know your whole story and I've listened
to like every podcast you've been on but
I also listen to people on the left I
love Destiny if you know who that is
he's great we had him on the podcast
he's super smart I love hearing him out
but one time I was on a date okay and I
pulled up my phone and I was searching
up something on YouTube and boom clicked
on YouTube Ben Shapiro shows up right
immediately like oh you listen to him
I'm like yeah I do I think he's got some
you know great opinions I'd like to hear
him out on certain things and boom kaput
entire day just absolutely ruined I'm
like do you know by the way about him
gentlemen excellent litmus test if you
do this and the girl runs you did the
right thing oh my gosh sure pull it down
I'm just like do you know anything about
him and she's like she's like I know
he's he's racist you know he's
anti-semite I'm like oh I'm like
anti-semite is my favorite anti-Semitism
I love that one yeah but but how do you
deal with this amount of hate and then
for the people that are ashamed to say
that they enjoy to hear you out on
certain things yeah I mean so for those
people listen I I totally understand
that there is cultural weight again and
listening to anybody on the right with
any level of popularity and and it
doesn't matter by the way that My Views
are significantly more nuanced on a wide
variety of topics than I think that
people believe they are right like if
you ask people on the left are you like
a huge super Trumper and then I tell
them I didn't vote in the 2016 election
because I thought that both candidates
sucked or that when I endorsed Donald
Trump in the 2020 election if you watch
my endorsement video I talked about all
of his personal failings and all of his
personality flaws and then I said I like
his policies better than Biden right
like like those sorts of things they
don't know I mean they don't know any of
this stuff but that's because the media
tend to paint and when I say to me I
really mean sort of the YouTube media
they paint a very sort of one-sided
picture listen we had to call up and
threaten to sue the economist because in
in headline they called me an alt-right
personality the all right hits my guts
I've gotten death threats from the alt
right they literally arrested some guy
for trying to kill my family a few years
ago the FBI did he went to jail for a
couple of years because I was too not
alright like I was the number one target
of online hate in 2015 like in all of in
all of the World online anti-Semitism
2015 2016. I was the number one Target
and it was almost entirely the alt-right
like none of that matters because the
media have decided that we're all in
these sort of reactionary boxes that's
why I take pride in the fact that we
have people from I mean
so on my show if people listen to my
show they'll they'll recognize that I
frequently I'd say at least once every
couple weeks we'll tell people you
should listen to my show and then you
should go listen to positive America I
literally say this on the show on a
routine basis go listen to the other
side listen to my side see which one you
think is more convincing I can attest to
that yeah this happens all the time at
some point we should put together a
montage of how many times I've told
people to go say
one of those parts of America won on
MSNBC and said that social media should
censor us and take us off the line
effectively like this it's not an even
game so I understand why people feel
that way because there is a weight of
that is also why you get the Counter
Culture thing that you were asking about
before because when there's that much
weight against a thing people sometimes
and then when they take a look at the
thing and they realize it isn't what
they've been told it opens up new worlds
to them so in some ways it's really
negative and really bad because it's
like people think a thing about me that
isn't true but on the other hand the
minute that people engage with the
content and they realize that that isn't
actually what the content is they're
like what else am I being lied about
because this isn't the person that I was
promised I was promised somebody who
hates black people I was promising
somebody who hates immigrants and
somebody who hates Muslims or hates Jews
most bizarrely or hates gay people or
something and instead what they get is
not that they're
they're really bewildered by it and they
think okay so I've been lied to about a
lot of things so in some ways the the
media's sort of universalistic
homogeneity with regard to what they say
I am and the contrast with what I
actually am is not the world's worst
thing as far as taking the incoming and
taking the hate
so back in
2017 2018 I used to obsess about Twitter
like really obsessed about it because
Twitter is just a giant ego machine
especially if you're somewhat notorious
if you have a certain number of
followers that the the verified stream
or the reply stream before that was
verified uh was like you want to feed
your ego just
we all tend to think of ourselves as
like the center of our own movie and the
center of our own story well ego Twitter
fed that because there's literally
people who are when you're famous
there's literally people who are talking
about every moment like thousands of
tweets an hour just about you and I
watched you know my friend Andrew
Breitbart
I think Twitter basically killed Andrew
I mean Andrew was obsessed with Twitter
um this is in the early days when 50 000
people was a lot to be following on
Twitter and he had you know a big
following at that point and he was just
obsess about what people were saying on
Twitter and reply and respond and all
that and it was really hard if I had
trend on Twitter and I trend on Twitter
I would say once every three weeks
almost like clockwork uh and at least
before Elon took over now it's a little
bit more rare because the algorithms
tend to be a little bit more honest
about what's happening but for for
several years it was like 172 once every
three weeks out of trend uh and every
day that would happen it would like ruin
my day and finally a few years ago my
wife said it's Rainier day you have kids
you have things to do just take Twitter
off your phone because you think
everybody is watching Twitter because
you're watching Twitter but nobody is
watching Twitter if you actually just
get off the phone and you walk around
there'll be a bunch of people who listen
to your show and they'll say how much
they enjoy your show and if you mention
to them what's going on Twitter they
will have no idea what you are talking
about and it is 100 true but what about
going to college campuses and seeing
people protest that I always find funny
I mean like I always find it funny
because first of all like
good for you you feel passionately about
the thing I have no problem with going
and protesting me you want to do that
total enjoy your first amendment that's
fine the things they protest me about
are some of the dumbest things
ever ever ever like my favorite one was
when I spoke at Boston University and
they protested me because they said I
was a racist like 200 people outside
saying I was a racist and I gave like a
45 minute disquisition on the history of
race in America that was almost entirely
about the evils of white supremacy for
the first you know 200 years of
America's existence and like going
through beat by beat and
they're protesting is like what in the
speech do you I said this at the time I
was like I need you to explain to me
what the speech you disagree with
or or I spoke I think it was at Stanford
and the entire speech was just about how
nasty and terrible the alt-right was and
I was getting protested as a fascist and
I was like I don't understand what you
want exactly like I'm I'm not doing this
for you and I'm fine with you being
pissed at me that's that's fine but do
you not have ears like the thing that
I'm saying what is the thing that I'm
saying right now that you find to be so
dangerous and so terrible and so
insulting that you are protesting me as
all of these terms racist sexist you
know homophobic all this kind of like
what is the thing that is scaring you so
much about what I'm saying that I'm
getting mislabeled those things like
name me the comment that I said and then
we can discuss whether I think that that
comment is taken out of context or
whether I misphed it or whether I think
it's right like we can we can talk about
those things
but you know it really goes like that so
whenever you're walking around in public
outside of the college campus protest
and stuff like that uh have you ever
gotten somebody that comes up to you and
actually starts saying super mean things
or like slandering you because it's
pretty rare it's it's rare it's rare
okay so I've I've personally never
experienced anything like that but I've
probably gotten thousands of hate
comments online yes but it's never
happened to the point where I meet
someone in person the internet is a
giant Hate Machine I mean like the the
because it's anonymous
how many times have you gone up to
somebody and berated them in public
never ever even people you don't like
but I also don't leave hate comments uh
I understand but like yeah that's that's
and and really neither do I although
I'll get kind of combative on Twitter
but the uh
how many people do you know who have
gone up in like berated randos in public
it just doesn't happen that often when
they do you think they're like a crazy
person so it really does not happen
nearly as much as you think it does what
you do get are like death threats in the
mail
you know you'll get people sending crap
to your house like that kind of stuff
does that worry you like ever for your
person we spend seven figures a year on
my personal safety yeah seven figures a
year on personal safety
wow yeah I mean that's just the way that
it goes yeah and then what about
traveling do you ever travel at security
do you travel you probably fly private
uh we we do fly private it depends where
I mean
if I'm flying abroad it's difficult to
fly private but um yeah domestically
we'll fly private sometimes we'll fly
commercial sometimes depends on what we
can do
um yeah I mean you try to avoid
particularly public places not really
because you think that somebody's gonna
take a shot at you although they might
but but more because uh there's the
possibility of a um
somebody coming up to you and taking a
swing at you or something and then then
it's a no-one situation because if you
if you take a punch and go down then the
entire inner and then the entire it's
like oh my god look somebody punched him
and oh they punch and if you fight back
then you go to jail so that's the
so it's so that's why security is really
security is really not there to stop me
from getting killed it's really it's
really there to stop these sorts of
things from happening and let people
know like if this happens there will be
people there to stop the thing that's
really what security is more about
one thing that you said I found
extremely interesting which was the
belief that everyone who has sinned is
not like me and the best protection of
evil is to recognize it in our own
hearts and you said I think that was on
Lex Friedman right can you expand on
that a little bit because I mean I like
to think that there's no real way in
which I could bend my morals and and do
something evil but I've also never been
presented with a opportunity maybe that
was as appetizing to do so I I don't
even think it's a matter of you know
presenting the opportunity as presented
the pressures or incentive structure I
mean the possibility of being an active
participant in something evil because
you believe that the others it's usually
a question of ends and means usually
evil and sin in the political realm at
least is a matter of ends and and means
where you think the ends are so
important that it justifies the means uh
and that that very often happens in
politics you'll just make excuses for
somebody doing something really really
bad because they're on your side and I I
don't like that and that that is a form
of sin and you have to be very careful
of that sort of stuff and those sorts of
sins are you know pretty common in
politics when we when we think of sin we
also tend to think of like the big sins
right we tend to think of like ten
commandments types in like oh I'd never
murder Bob well I mean that's that's
true I assume you would never murder Bob
um but I'm not going to assume that you
would never you know bear false witness
against your neighbor because that's a
pretty broad one and so there might be a
situation in which you're in an awkward
conversation and you just kind of like
spin what he said a little bit
differently for the approval of people
who are looking on and we're all
performing small sins every day uh but
you know what does Smalls and what's a
big sin no I said that's that can
sometimes be a matter of opinion but I
think that that's the nature of what
religious belief is about is that you
you should constantly be looking at
looking at yourself and and trying to
see what you could be doing better you
also mentioned on on Lex Friedman that
it's not very good advice to say be a
good dad or sorry be a good person
because it's true it's too broad it's
too big but if you say something like be
a good dad most people intrinsically
they know what that is yes for me
someone that doesn't have a kid yet and
I always imagine how I'm going to raise
my child but I still have no idea like
when do I intervene when do I tell them
that this is good versus this is bad or
do I let them figure it out for
themselves how do you know how to be a
good dad well so I have models I think
my dad is an amazing dad
um but I think that the the
there are a few kind of quick rules to
being a good dad one is that you
actually have to respect your children
as though they have you know cognizable
bushes which sometimes can be hard
because you know they're not kids are
not famous for being smart they're small
they're children they're not supposed to
be adults but you have to actually treat
them with a certain level of respect and
you have to treat them as though their
desires are are meaningful you also have
to say no and you have to set rules and
you have to be willing to stick by those
rules because it's your job to craft
this person into a person who's capable
of being a good dad of his own so think
about what you want your kid to be like
as an ad that might actually be an
interesting way of doing it what what
would you think that if you saw your kid
you're now a grandfather your kid is
interacting with their kid what does
that look like in a way that you approve
of because you because that you probably
have some general I mean it depends who
the male father figures are in your life
the truth is it's hard to see how that
works without modeling
right this is why
single single motherhood has been such a
dramatic failure for the United States
is because Boys in particular really
really need father figures to model what
it looks like to be a good man and when
you remove that father figure that is
not fillable by a woman it's just not
men and women are different there's no
such thing as a woman who can be a
father it's not it's not the same
um that's not say a woman can be an
unbelievable mother and fill gaps that
exist in different ways but she's not
going to be an ad those are two
different category things it's a
category error um but yeah I mean there
are certain so I think that they're
we're not saying that there's an
intrinsic sort of set of things you know
that are that are a bit you know what
it's like to be a bad dad you can always
start you can start with that right I
mean like I always find so that in in
Judaism there are two types of
Commandments there's uh mits what I say
meaning like the things that you do and
then there's Mitzvah said like the
things you can't do and I find that in
most circumstances we tend to focus on
things we can do rather than things that
we shouldn't but it's sometimes easier
to do it by process elimination in this
situation would you smack your kid no in
this situation would you yell at your
kid publicly no in this situation would
you would you lecture your kid or or you
know like there are certain things that
you just wouldn't do and then there's a
lot of gray area in there too it's not
like there's only one like the best way
to be a parent there's there's too much
action there's too much sticking and
moving but you know what it's like to be
a bad dad and by contrast that does
leave a fairly wide area to be a
mediocre to good dad who does it right
on the left
um in terms of having conversations uh
so
I think that
Independence you consider to be on the
left most of the people who I think of
is doing it right are actually more now
considered Centrist even though their
political viewpoints are probably not
they're like Joe Rogan is not a right
winger Joe Rogan is probably not even a
Centrist right he said he would vote for
Bernie Sanders he's liberal on all the
social issues
um he's he's kind of a socialist when it
comes to economics at least he says he
is even though I don't think in practice
he really is uh like by any classical
definition Joe is much more on the left
than he is on the right I think Joe is
really good at what he does
um I think that you know they're they're
some folks like Brett Weinstein who's
clearly identified as on the left who I
think does it right it's easier for me
to to sort of check off people one by
one so if you threw names with me I can
tell you whether I think they are or not
but um
in terms of sort of
mainstreaming at cable news it's hard to
think of people who are doing it right
there are people who do it better than
others like I think Jake Tapper does it
better than Chuck Todd for example when
it comes to uh sort of online YouTube
land Destiny would be an example of
somebody who I think does it better than
some of the other people who argue
online why don't you debate destiny I
mean I'd be interested in debating
Destiny fantastic yeah yeah we had such
a great conversation with him for three
hours I believe he has a lot of depth to
his beliefs which I admire right he
seems like he's thought things through
which makes for an interesting
conversation yeah and my one rule and
again the is that if people are like
radically personally insulting toward me
or if I feel like I'm gonna be
sandbagged in a debate then that's not a
debate anymore it's an insult comic
contest and so I'm not super interested
in that so
um that is my one Proviso but I haven't
watched all Destiny stuff so I'm not
religious although my family they're
they're all Jewish and I uh I've never
really been to synagogue or I've never
been to church my father's side's a
little bit Christian I'm wondering if
you need to be religious or spiritual in
some capacity to live life and have it
be as meaningful as it possibly can be
or if you can find just as much
fulfillment and meaning while being uh I
would say like not religious so I I I
can't speak for every single human so
I'm not going to say that there are
people who can't find that or it's
impossible to find that I will say that
it doesn't scale
that if I'm talking to like an average
person I don't know anything about you
then I would say that yes a religious
life is going to be a better life it
leads you on a pathway toward
understanding that there's more in life
than you that your moral system is not
the only moral system nor is it a moral
system that is irrefutable uh that there
is a higher goal to life there's certain
premises I think that everybody lives
based off of that are effectively
religious that they refuse to
acknowledge Free Will being one of them
the notion would live in an
understandable universe that we are
capable of actually exploring being
another one of them the notion that
human life is of innate value I think
that's an assumption that is based on
nothing if you're not a religious person
if you're a religious person you say
this because we're all made in the image
of God if you're not religious person
then I don't know on a logical level why
a human life would be any more valuable
than an elephant life or or a squirrel
life
um you can make an emotional argument
perhaps but I don't think that you can
make a perfectly logical one because
there's nothing about a human being that
is any different than any other piece of
meat on sort of a material Level and you
can say that that meat has different
properties but why are those properties
more valuable like what why is
consciousness valuable for example like
what in order to say the Consciousness
is valuable you have to say the
Consciousness is good okay how do you
define good
good for what morally good now you're
talking about an Israel Gap that can't
be bridged by atheism or agnosticism so
can you live a life on a practical level
that is happy and fulfilled while not
filling those gaps sure you could does
it scale not remotely is that going to
work for millions of people no that's
why secular humanism is a failure as a
project it collapses pretty quickly into
moral relativism moral relativism
narcissism Hedonism and that's what
you're watching is the as the birth
rates in the west collapse and as people
in more and more are caught up in their
own internal subjective assessments of
self as like the key to all human
existence what's your biggest insecurity
it's hard for me because honestly I have
a really really good life so I mean
you're asking
can I ask for uh to drill down on the
question you mean like thing I'm worried
about or thing that I I look in myself
and I see a flaw you look in yourself
and you see a flaw oh I mean I'm quick
to form opinions so I have to try to you
know militate against that by you know
actively saying okay wait a second and
like and do the reading
um I'm I can be intolerant of opinions
that I think are dumb and so sometimes
that comes across interpersonally I can
be
too cool in my calculations to other
people's emotions uh you know the facts
don't care about your feelings thing is
true on a political level but
interpersonally it can't be true and
feelings certainly matter on an
interpersonal level so the those would
probably be the the big ones and I have
to ask where do you invest your money
because you've been very Diversified
throughout your career yeah it's cold
virgin
so where do I invest my money uh so as
I'm sure your listeners know there's a
big difference between wealth and actual
like liquid assets sure so obviously I
am invested very heavily in Daily wire
in the sense that I own a large chunk of
daily wire and that's a very large
business so if you were to assess my net
wealth that is a large portion of my net
wealth however in terms of like my
actual s liquid asset base
um I I have always
thought in the same way that I think
about my career that if I cannot
dedicate a lot of time to a thing I
shouldn't be doing the thing and so I
have financial advisors who essentially
I told them I'm young I have a very
solid cash flow so I want you to take
the best Diversified portfolio in sort
of your highest risk category so uh I'm
willing to lose the money right
basically there's like my solid stuff
that I want there's a certain percentage
of my portfolio that I think of is like
very solid it's not going to be 80 yeah
and then there's like 15 which is in
like the more high risk category maybe
maybe 30 percent versus fifty and then
the and it's probably going like
50 is in very kind of low risk solid
returning assets 30 is in more of a high
risk bundle 20 is reserved for like go
for it sure uh and uh but when I say go
for it they don't really do that there's
there's only one investment I've only
made one investment in my life where I
uh where I personally quote unquote
picked a stock because I don't think
that you can day trade Without Really
knowing a lot about a thing and my
strategy on investment is uh is
graham.strategy so I I Benjamin Graham
and David Dodd so the the which is the
same strategy Warren Buffett uses which
is essentially you're not investing in
risks you're mitigating your downside
risk and looking at the possibility of
upside and when you buy a piece of stock
you're not buying a piece of stock
because you think the value is going to
go up you're buying a piece of stock
because you want a piece of that company
because the company is well run has a
good product has good upside and so I
don't buy things to sell them I buy
things to hold them yeah um and and so
again I'm young and that's all you have
to do right I mean if you just buy
things to hold them and you don't pick
like the worst stocks in the entire
world you the magic of compound interest
is a thing and so for me it's the first
rule is don't lose and then and the
second and then the second thing that
you can do is look at potential upsides
so for example I'm now a major
stockholder and on the board of a
publicly traded NASDAQ Corporation
that's like a biotech company the way
that I picked that stock is I happen to
know the CEO
um and I know that he's a very solid guy
and I know that he makes good decisions
and the stock was wildly undervalued I
know how much through public disclosures
I knew how much cash they had on their
books and I saw that the the company was
trading at one half of its cash and so I
was like well it's trading one half it's
cash
from all available public indicators it
doesn't and the last few quarterly
reports they don't have like significant
burn so why is it trading at one half of
its cash that's it that's an
undervaluation so I bought up a bunch of
that stock and the reason it was trading
under its cash is because it had a drug
it failed to phase three trial it dumped
from you know 20 bucks a share to like
two bucks a share and so everybody else
was like they're buying it on the way up
and I was like well no I'm gonna wait
and now now dump but it's got a big bag
of cash right here that's worth at least
four dollars a share I can buy you two
dollars a share there's no risk yeah
what about alternative Investments
because I've noticed that's a Zenith
Rolex Daytona yeah yeah you know you're
watching yeah that's right uh so yeah I
do have a bit of a watch collection
um mainly because they're pieces of art
but again buy to hold meaning like
watches as a as sort of a hobby slash
investment are are good because
depending on the brand uh and that's
basically you need one of the big three
or a uh or Rolex those are the ones that
will actually accrue in value over time
if you hold on to them long enough uh
there are a lot of other beautiful watch
watches Jaeger makes beautiful stuff but
tends to on the gray market sell for
less than its price
um but watches are great because you get
to wear them around and then if you
don't like them anymore you can sell
them and not lose any money which is
more than you can save for the vast
majority of other sort of luxury assets
so you buy a nice car and and within
five seconds it's worth half of what it
was when you bought it so yeah it's a
yeah I have the original 1969 uh the el
primero so the same movement as that
yeah so what I really wanted was a
stainless steel version of that and then
prices not so they did but now they're
coming back down slowly all the Bitcoin
guys have bought watches and then when
Bitcoin went blast like a year and a
half ago then so this is the mistake
that I made I bought a couple of
paddocks and I bought them when uh like
at the at the height of the like just on
the other side of the height I was like
oh they're dropping we're good I didn't
weigh long enough and so yeah I I didn't
do well on those
um but again my view is I wasn't selling
them in the next year so what do I care
right just hold on I'll give my son
that's fine that's the this is a Jordan
Peterson person-esque question it's a
nice Ender to a viewer that's watching
that maybe isn't just happy they're not
finding themselves like optimistic and
positive when they wake up in the
morning which is a great indicator of
your just overall mental well-being how
do you advise that they become happy and
live a good and meaningful life you have
to do things you really have to do
things and that sounds vague but it
means like when Jordan says make your
bed he means it like actively make your
bed like do do the small things that
give you a sense of activity and purpose
in the world and that could be
volunteering at a local charity if
that's the thing that you want to do or
it could mean that you need to search
for a job if you don't get a job today
it could mean that you have to there's a
great episode I don't know if you guys
watch the bear on FX phenomenal it's a
great show and season two there's an
episode where this guy is kind of a
nerdy well and he's kind of a he's kind
of a boorish
jerk and he is it's about a restaurant
in Chicago
um and they're season two they're trying
to build this into like a beautiful
restaurant and one of the people who
sort of hold over is a negative down guy
and the the his his friend slash cousin
sends him to go learn how to Stage like
a five-star restaurant with a Michelin
star
um and he um and the entire episode is
he starts off and he's just their
cleaning forks that's all they'll allow
them to do it like you need to clean the
forks and they keep coming back and
they're like they're streaks on the
forks he's like why do I give it what do
I care if there's a streak on the floor
because like there's a streak on the
fork you're gonna clean these Forks
they're all gonna have no streaks on
them because it's not a restaurant that
does drinks on forks and then he's told
like he and then he learns and he sort
of imbibes that ethic and suddenly he's
like oh I see this is a restaurant that
doesn't have streaks on Forks that means
that I have to come in here in a suit
that means that I have to actually up my
game that means that I have to so like
doing the Small Things leads to the
bigger things this is actually quite
it's both an Aristotelian concept and a
very judaic concept people tend to think
of of The Commandments in Judaism and
it's vote the things that you do it's
like oh they're these weird things that
you do every day right you get up in the
morning you wash your hands in a certain
way or you get up in the morning and you
pray and then you say a blessing before
you eat and then you eat and then you
say Another Blessing after you eat and
it's all very formulaic and why are you
doing all these things and the answer is
do the small things and do them well and
it allows you a pathway to virtue that's
the difference between sort of Plato and
Aristotle Plato basically says that you
you grasp the big idea and that maybe
leads to Virtue and Aristotle's like do
all of these things and that leads you
to cultivate virtue um and so Judaism is
very much a recitalian in that sense
it's like get up in the morning do this
is why I think the framework of religion
is super helpful for a lot of people
because it gives them a thing to do
every day you're going to do the thing
you might not like doing the thing you
may not be in the mood to do the thing
in the mood is one of the worst ideas
anybody ever came up with who cares
whether you're in the mood I'm in the
mood to get up with my kids at 5 45 in
the morning's in the mood to do that but
doing that thing is what gives you
meaning in life
yeah in the mood is really stupid so
like the the
you're depressed you're not going to
stop being depressed by being in the bad
you can either be depressed being in the
bed or you can be depressed while you do
a thing and then it may turn out that as
you do the thing you become less
depressed change change what you do and
it may change your emotional state I
heard a great quote that was happiness
and meaning is not to be pursued but it
will ensue which I think I think that's
right it sums that up Ben thank you so
much hey thanks guys I really appreciate
it is like a Monumental moment in my
life and I'm just I'm just so happy that
you've never seen Jack so happy for a
guest ever no in the entire history
we started the podcast specifically to
one day have you on it that's awesome I
appreciate it guys this is cool well
thank you thank you so much and with
that said you guys until next time until
next time uh